salut comment ça va aller changement
l'éclairage est pas du tout optimale ici
c'est complètement le bordel dans le
studio mais gardez vous avez un bout de
raiden qui est là c'est vraiment posé un
polar je pense qu'à des changements il
manque des pieds les choses vont arriver
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer un truc
père des peuples à venir ici j'ai posé
vraiment une lumière à la rage donc
c'est de faire gaffe je vous prête le
smartphone c'est le raid magic c'est le
ced pros ont sorti le 7 ya pas longtemps
raid magic sagan nubia tout ça alors je
vous en parlais pourquoi de smartphones
parce qu'il est intéressant parce que en
termes de smartphones de game mix un
monstre absolu c'est un truc de dingue
je vous racontais l'histoire ce truc là
vous allez voir c'est assez intéressant
malien du mans mais génial
[Musique]
von wrede magic 7 pro c'est quoi c'est
cette espèce de grosse bête là vraiment
que je fasse gaffe on seulement parce
que vraiment de prendre l'éclairage dans
la tronche qui je pourrais vous montrer
mais ça sera un peu absurde il vraiment
posé là vous avez la cs3 là vous avez un
gh5 et vous avez monté carasso qui est
posée vraiment la rage entre les deux
j'ai juste content fait de ce que je
fais mais bon regardez je vais vous
montrer c'est le temps que je change des
choses regardez c'est vraiment opposés
mais complètement à la hache donc ceci
explique cela donc voilà soyez pas
surpris je suis un peu la rage mais j'ai
des éclairages qui vont arriver là donc
demain normalement donc pour ça devrait
aller en attendant c'est un peu
l'aventuré ici donc ce smartphone il est
intéressant pourquoi ce smartphone il
est intéressant parce que il ya plein de
points qui sont cool si vous voulez
c'est pour montrer vraiment là où vannes
ou bien au niveau du gaming pour autant
est-ce que c'est un smartphone qu'il
faut venir acheter je ne suis pas
convaincu ça pour plusieurs points mais
avant de vous en parler je vous montrais
la boîte parce que je trouve magnifique
et je trouve que là dessus ils ont mais
vraiment super bien bossé regardez moi
cette design il assez exceptionnel c'est
toujours très très beau ce qu'ils font à
regarder voilà je le trouve ça juste
juste super beau et je voulais je
voulais vous le montrer alors à
l'intérieur après c'est un peu moins fou
parce que alors effectivement on arrive
là red magic c'est beau c'est sympa ça
fonctionne là vous avez normalement le
smartphone et ça c'est un peu un peu
moins classe qu'on voyait avec le bout
de câble et le truc positif comme ça on
peut à larache c'est pas terrible pour
mener le chargeur usb c'est un peu son
art mais ça conviendra ya pas de souci
là-dessus alors moi j'ai un bloc de
chasse gardée si c'est vraiment posé
c'est un peu la rage alors moi c'est pas
un bloc français vous vous aurez un blog
français moi c'est un produit presse
alors c'est un produit parce qu'il sera
un peu différent de vote parce que le
modèle que j'ai moi il dit 8 gigas de
ram si ça vous intéresse c'est un
smartphone que vous pouvez trouver en 16
giga drame en config 256 ou 512 giga de
stockage mais vous l'aurez jamais en 18
giga de ram voilà nubia je pense a voulu
dire on va faire du 18 donc ils ont
fabriqué les symboles pour les prix
presse et après son duo pop pop pop pop
c'est peut-être pas la bonne idée on a
peut-être pas faire ça donc ok donc ça
c'est pour la boîte maintenant je veux
qu'on parle du smartphone en lui-même
parce que le smartphone il est
intéressant alors c'est une masse à il
fait 200 combien j'ai noté 235 grammes
soit il faire un peu de muscu avec sa
fédé petit haltère il est attaquant sur
plusieurs points le premier point qui va
être vachement cool c'est que peuple à
capteur d'empreintes digitales voilà ça
déverrouille c'est que vous avez une
caméra sous l'écran donc votre caméra on
la voit mais absolument mais absolument
pas et pour autant et si tu es là donc
ça c'est vraiment une fois de plus
plutôt bien c'est une techno qui
regardent et hop là je suis là la caméra
est juste là après il ya un côté un peu
voilent envoyée c'est pas parfait 1
c'est loin de l'être et je suis pas
convaincu que ce soit un truc on fera de
superbes photos mais bon alors je vais
pas entrer dans la partie photo parce
que c'est un smartphone de gaming donc
la partie photo on s'en fout un peu on
va pas les devants mais voyez je suis
vraiment pas convaincu par la caméra de
salfit par contre ce qui est vraiment
bien et là où je suis convaincu c'est
que je trouve qu'ils ont vraiment bien
intégrés pour coup c'est vraiment
vraiment bien caché que vous jouiez à
des jeux où que vous regardiez une série
sur netflix regarder aller là là je
trouve que c'est quand même vachement
bien réussi et super bien caché alors
franchement ce smartphone il n'est pas
extrêmement lumineux je le pousse à fond
on est jusqu'à 2 700 dit ça c'est le
maximum qu'on pouvoir avoir ici donc
sept caméras planquées sous l'écran vous
en parle depuis un bon petit moment au
niveau de différents constructeurs je
trouve qu'ici nubia bien réussi est bien
joué le coup donc ça c'est cool il ya un
autre truc qui est intéressant nous
t'attaquerons alors on a un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz ok on
connaît il y avait un modèle était pas
le modèle pro qui était monté à 144 m
celui là il reste à 120 m mais bon
pourquoi pas vous avez ici en plus un
écran amoled c'est du full hd + ratio
22e ok on est sur un 6 8 pouces et une
très très grosse diagonale attention ici
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est le
taux d'échantillonnage tactile ou vous
monter jusqu'à 960 hertz à le regarder
je vais vous mettre un petit jeu dès que
j'allume ma je vous avais un brouillard
regardez écoutez ça c'est le ventilateur
vous avez un ventilateur qui à l'arrière
qui sont cachés ici là alors je vous le
montrez pas ce qu'on peut bien l'activé
directement manuellement on la veut dire
dans le raid magic 7 ce ventilateur il
va jusqu'à vingt mille tours par minute
c'est à dire en famille en une minute
vous fait vingt mille tours donc le truc
est complètement dingos garder il est là
alors il ya des petites lumières en même
temps des petites led là c'est assez
sympa alors vous n'êtes pas obligé vous
pouvez désactiver lorsque vous lancez un
jeu parce que ça fait un peu de bruit
vous avez en plus la sortie qui est
juste là ce qui fait quand vous prenez
votre main comme ça mais vous sentez
vous bloquez un peu la sortie et ça
c'est un peu un peu ballot mais bon
après il ya quand même un côté qui est
plutôt pas mal on va venir re un froid
dire son smartphone très très facilement
donc ça c'est cool et je trouve ça
plutôt bien peuple à regarder on se
prend une voiture et on va lui faire un
petit tour directement ici alors j'ai
fait un peu d'humain peu de pub j j'ai
fait un peu d'asphalté neuf avec
histoire un peu de marée et voyez le
ventilateur moi je l'entends je pense
qu'ils attendent et vous on l'entend
quand même up la petite partie histoire
de se marrer très très rapidement au
peuple up la tac tac tac walhalla les
saltos de dingue on est des yeux d'un on
aime ça donc voilà donc c'est sympa
alors ici taux d'échantillonnage taquet
radio plage de mettre ici ça ne m'est
pas la poste mais c'est pas grave vous
allez l'avoir ici dans les paramètres ce
que c'est tout un mode jeu alors
attendez moi je veux dès qu'on aille
dans ici la voyez je suis en
480 hertz je peux monter en 960 m mais
ils vous disent attention ça va
consommer davantage ça va tirer au
niveau de la batterie je peux régler la
sensibilité
enfin il ya pas mal de petites options
qui sont très pratiques ici même au
niveau des zones je peux choisir combat
performance si je veux y aller à fond
les ballons des bons autonomie va pas
être dingue c'est le seul truc aussi en
mode eco mais ce qu'on veut c'est
l'impuissance donc on va se mettre ici
en balade je peux choisir ce que je veux
au niveau de mes couleurs si j'ai un
truc un peu plus équilibré à l'école de
pose là ça me bloque la sortie d'air cet
outil un peu ballot après je te dire
enregistré je peux venir paramétrer mais
trigger que j'ai sur le dessus ici la
voyait un petit rigueur là et un petit
rigueur là pour venir jouer directement
avec mes doigts si je souhaite donc ya
un côté très sympa ici même en étant là
je suis quand même en quatrième position
au sens strict te ment c'est n'importe
quoi ce jeu fini parce que j'aime pas
j'aime pas perdre mais si je suis un peu
à la ramasse hop là les bim bim bim bim
bim bim bim bim pif paf pouf on y va je
suis ni premier lange a rien fait c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi soit neuf donc
voilà il ya pas mal de petites options
au niveau logiciel c'est plutôt pas mal
et bien optimisé après le truc alors on
voit ce qu'ils ont montré ici c'est de
se dire on a une bête de course en un
truc de fou avec le petit ventilateur la
rue petit ventilateur pour venir vous
choisir de l'activé directement si vous
souhaitez regarder sur votre écran
d'accueil ils vous ont bien un petit
widget vous appuyer là et sélective
s'allume donc ça c'est assez rigolo est
ce qu'on va venir retrouver ici alors
après est ce que j'aime bien aussi c'est
je trouve que le dos ils ont également
bien travaillé ils ont un truc est très
sympa il vous le mark vous êtes une
batterie de 5000 méliand père heures
vous avez le snapdragon 8 jean one qui
est ici enfin bref ils vous ont fait un
truc est quand même vachement mal et
après il ya un truc que nous a fait du
bien ici c'est qu'ils ont mis une puce
dédiée en plus du snapdragon la puce et
l'arrêtent corps un raid comme moi
l'idée de l'art et de core 1 que vous
allez avoir ici c'est non pas d'apporter
de la performance au niveau cpu haut
niveau gpu l'idée c'est de venir
soulager le snapdragon en venant prendre
des actions qu'on ne lui confiera pas
lui sans lui donner le maximum de
latitude pour venir bosser à fond
notamment la gestion de l'audio la
gestion des led est également le toucher
un petit bonbon plutôt pas mal alors ici
ils ont mis le paquet aussi au niveau
des techno il plaidé hier 5 au niveau de
la ram on a ici je vous dis lumière si
c'est d'ici que vous aurez 16 giga de
ram on peut rajouter si giga de ram en
plus c'est assez énorme avec de la ram
virtuel le stockage c'est lui ai fais
trois points ça fonctionnera également
d'envoyer ils ont quand même vraiment
mis le paquet au niveau du smartphone
grosse batterie de 5000 millions période
mais on a de la recharge 65 watts dans
la boîte mais bon très honnêtement je
vous dis je joue un peu avec ça va pas
durer longtemps ça descend relativement
vite si vous vous remettez avec un
touché tactile à 960 r si vous mettez
donc forcément 100 verte non adaptatif
choisissez entre je vous le montre un 60
90 ou 120 donc le tout qu'y un peu qu'on
en fait que ce soit pas adaptatif c'est
quand même relativement dommage vous
venez dans écran ici vous l'avez cédant
tac voyez vous êtes soit en 60 soit 90
sont en 120 c'est pas dati ça c'est
vraiment vraiment dommage il ya un autre
truc qui un peu pas office il sait que
c'est très très mal traduit regarder
même si quasiment pas traduit par
endroits donc là on est bien dans écran
au niveau de luminosité et la chose
queenwell fâche wright ok super je m'en
fous il ya plein de trucs qui sont pas
du tout traduit des cours en français
des coûts en anglais alors j'imagine
c'est qu'une partie logicielle ça
pouvait être mis à jour mais c'est quand
même un peu dommage et ça vient casser
un peu l'expérience après qu'avant dans
un smartphone de guy mineault avoir de
la vibration optique non pas mal je pars
extrêmement fans ça peut tenter
notamment sont vraiment un truc dédié
gaming autre truc qui est assez marrant
c'est que vous avez une prise jack
regardez ça c'est assez conserver donc
si vous voulez vous utilisez une prise
jack un casse avec une prise jack vous
pouvez le faire très facilement autres
points également qui est intéressant
vous avez des hauts parleurs stéréo bon
sens on doutera c'est quand même pas
tout nouveau l'histoire ça marche plutôt
bien mais est ce qui est intéressant ce
que je trouve qu'ils sont plutôt pas mal
et ça criait vraiment vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de niveaux
regardez
ça fait médium à part qu'on sait
c'est pas mal la partie audio est pas
mal là dessus en plus d'abaisser
d'ubuntu 5.26 voulait venir après un
casque sans fils sans problème donc why
not donc c'est assez marrant fait ce
qu'elle lui faire nubia avec son raid
magic c'est qu'ils viennent pousser un
peu plus les limites la partie photo je
vous demande pas parce qu'on est un
cafard se sont tus mégapixels on a un
ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et on
doit voir le capteur de profondeur de 2
mégapixels 10,2 mégapixels ne vous
disent pas ce que c'est je pense que
c'est un capteur de profondeur très
honnêtement c'est pas un smartphone qui
va être fait pour faire de la photo ici
ce qu'on veut c'est de montrer la
puissance montrer la performance montrer
ce que sait faire nubia jouer le côté un
peu sympa avec ce ventilateur qui vient
tournée qui fait de la lumière mais
au-delà de ça il a globalement pas grand
chose derrière pour nous en tout cas ici
en france et en europe ce smartphone je
trouve intéressant je voulais vous
présenter parce que d'un côté gaming je
trouve vraiment marrant très puissant
avec effectivement ce petit ventilateur
là on peut aller plus loin d'un an peut
venir ajouté différentes lumières d'être
bref je passe un peu le truc c'est un
smartphone de gainey l'air assez pour
moi il est beaucoup trop lourd il est
pas bien traduit il même très très très
mal traduites même par endroits pas du
tout traduit ce qui vient de
disqualifier assez rapidement néanmoins
je voulais vous le montre ce que je
trouve intéressant je sais pas ce que
vous bottez vous un smartphone de gaming
comme ça comme le raid magics est trop
de nubia dites le moi en commentaire et
puis dites moi si vous voulez qu'on
aille plus loin sur des textes de ce
smartphone là où d'autres hein parce que
je sais qu'il ya black shark a sorti
aussi un smartphone ya pas longtemps ou
si vous voulez compter les smartphones
de gimme dites le moi en bas dans les
commentaires voilà c'était plantations
un peu rapide mais bon on a fait le tour
a je pense qu'on a vu ce qu'ils avaient
à voir je vous embrasse pour l'espagne
brouillent à très bientôt
[Musique]